these goats dude they're all spooky I'm  gonna pick that one over I'll cross the  street  forty years ago on Halloween night  Michael Myers murdered three people  after that horrific night he was sent  back to the institution in captivity  I have prayed her every night that he  would escape the Bell did you do that  for  so I can kill him the bus crashed  Michael Myers escaped who returned to  have him filled his home I need to  protect my family you have no security  system Karen you need help evil is real  there's the reason we're supposed to be  afraid of the sight I've been preparing  for this for a long time it is not safe  to be on the street tonight he's here he  is a killer but he will be killed  tonight  happy Halloween Michael  you  [Music]  you